oh no a little surprise for you speaking
of international I was recently in
London and I had a chance to talk to
some of the actors and I couldn't resist
the opportunity to ask them if there was
a character in this series in Game of
Thrones that reminds them of you oh dear
no I take I hope you liked it
yes there is but I'm not gonna say
didn't George once say that he felt he
was Tyrion yes yeah definitely I
definitely would see that definitely
would see that Tyrion is it's obviously
his favorite right I mean it's an
incredible character incredible
character and yeah I drew which is so
that would make complete sense no no no
hmm
well he's he's got little sparrows all
over the place Varys yes do you not
think so
Sam well because he's knowledgeable and
when you asked George about when I asked
George about what's happening he always
gives you a riddle he doesn't give you
the full answer and I think there is he
has that innocent innocent perspective
for the world and there's it's all the
peace in his mind and he's very good
harder but I know he has a soft spot for
Davos thank you I think he's written
them they're all part of him I guess
how can you say that on
[Laughter]
[Music]
well that was fun to do so they're all
part right yeah they're all bride was
gonna say who's right no they were what
well Tyrion is my favorite there's
there's no doubt about that
you know he's he he's the easiest to
write at least for the first three books
he was the easiest to write hmm
he got harder to write with book 5 in
particular because he's in a very dark
place right there and but he's witty and
he's intelligent and Tyrion is almost
like what I wish I could because I'm not
as wittiest here Ian oh I am as witty as
Tyrion because I invent all of the witty
things of scary stuff the problem is of
course that Tyrion tosses off these
witty lines in you know ease in with
ease in the moment of conversation and I
of course in real life think of the
witty thing to say a week after the
conversation that would have been really
funny and cutting and things like that
yeah so I don't think of these things as
fast but Sam yeah is there's a lot of me
in Sam - yeah girls are screaming for
that one what you know there there's all
of the viewpoint characters I have to
put something of myself into it to make
them come alive in even the ones that
are you know very unlike me on the
surface like you know 11 year old girls
you know I've obviously never been an 11
year old girl I have known an occasional
11 year old girl especially when I was
11 year old boy although actually when I
was 11 year old boy I was too scared to
talk to Livan year overall so I was more
like Sam in that regard it's interesting
news look elio who George mentioned
earlier and you know created Westeros
org I met him in London and we were
talking about how we both thought that
Tyrion was your favorite and that was
and what we were musing about it's not a
good thing for Tyrion because you put
this guy through hell and back again so
doesn't
benefit Tyrion that he is your favorite
no probably not it doesn't cover at all
it does not help them and in really in
dance with dragons he goes through the
most hellish stuff yet so uh you know
he's he's at an ad or there so you try
not to play favorites I suppose and
maybe you put your first but I put all
the characters through horrible things
you know that's uh I I get letters from
fans and say well why why do you hate to
start so much why do you put them why do
you put them so through many horrible
things but you know the Lannisters have
been through some pretty horrible things
too lately and you know the Baratheon's
have gone through an awful lot of
horrible stuff
the Targaryen Zara practically all wiped
out except for Danny yeah you know so
everybody yeah you know it's it's the
Middle Ages and it's hard life is hard
and nasty and short and brutal and you
never noticed the way it is but it's fun
to read about I hope yes